a long time ago in an office far far
away loads of Disney marketing
executives put together a plan to
saturate the world with Star Wars we are
now suffering or enjoying the
consequences the latest in the barrage
of media coverage is a new teaser that
shows off the dark side I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update
another new teaser for star wars the
force awakens has arrived courtesy of
the official Star Wars Facebook page
like with previous TV spots featuring
Finn and Ray this one puts the spotlight
on a new character namely the evil kylo
Ren and the dark forces of the first
order earlier this week it was confirmed
at the film will carry a pg-13 rating in
the US for sci-fi action violence the
previous Star Wars film 2005's Revenge
of the Sith also carried this rating
while the prior films in the series were
all rated PG it's only a few short weeks
until we can all go to the cinema at the
same time to pay our respects to the
great lens flare God JJ Abrams find out
who dies in the first half hour and
check out what all the original cast up
like 40 years later are you going to see
the film on launch day do you think the
dark side that's cooler than the light
side or are you still hiding under your
star trek bedsheets and hoping it all
goes away soon let us know in the
comments I'm Kate you can find me on
Twitter at how not to draw and remember
to keep it gamespot com for all your
gaming and entertainment news